this is a production of Cornell
University
Thank You Marvin hi everyone thank you
so much for coming to my seminar today
we're going to be talking about
strawberry in New York we're going to be
talking about the differences that you
can see when you taste a strawberry and
how they might actually be connected to
the management practices as people grow
them so to start I want to ask you all
to show your hands if you've ever had a
similar experience to this have you all
ever gone to the grocery store and you
see on display this beautiful basket of
strawberries they look juicy they're
shiny they're plump and you're just
totally sold you take them home sit down
take a bite and it's sour and it tastes
maybe a little bit like cardboard but
certainly not like what you were
expecting
show of hands anyone else thank you I
feel so vindicated so of course there
are a lot of differences in strawberry
quality and you know what to expect when
you buy that basket of strawberries you
know what you're hoping to taste and it
can really disappoint and of course some
of the reasons why those strawberries
taste different from what you expect
might be due to the variety being not
the same or often if you buy a grocery
store strawberries especially in the
winter they had to be picked a little
bit under right because they had to make
all their way from California or Florida
to New York State but there are other
factors also that get lots of
speculation about why they may cause
differences and taste so you hear
discussions about how nutritious the
soil is how well nourish the plant is we
there's also plenty of discourse on the
use and intensity of use of agricultural
chemicals so this gets played out a lot
in the organic versus conventional
discussion so strawberries are I think
fruits with a remarkable range of
tasting good to tasting bad and so this
discourse over conventional versus
organic can take interesting turns both
in more public spheres like Yahoo
Answers but also there are studies that
are rather newsworthy and can make their
way into food
like kitchen where there are lots of
discussions about what's going on with
strawberries and does organic really
make a difference so one really
interesting study examining the
difference is specifically between
organic and conventional strawberries
was Reginald at all the study published
in 2010 but the research was conducted
in 2004 and 2005 so the authors found
that when comparing organic versus
conventional strawberries while
controlling for cultivar and soil type
there's actually remarkable difference
in favor of organic they took
strawberries from paired farms where
they would take one farm that was
organic for five years or more and one
farm really close to it that was
conventional for five years or more and
they compared organic and conventional
strawberries from these two farms they
subject the strawberries to an intense
assay of phenolic tests to sensory
evaluation and they found that really
the organic strawberries outperformed in
every single parameter that they tested
they were found to be juicier they were
found to be tastier by the sensory
panelists they had much higher phenolic
content and they even had a better shelf
life so those organic strawberries were
really something special and the authors
concluded that the driving force behind
the high quality of the organic
strawberries was the remarkable higher
quality of the organic farm soil so this
is a really interesting finding but when
you take a little bit of a closer look
you noticed that this study was
conducted in California at the time of
the study California produced 25 percent
of the world's strawberries and that
number has grown since then
so this study was actually conducted in
the county in California that is the
highest strawberry producing county in
the state so this study controlled for
the soil type and for the variety but
not really for microclimate and they
didn't control for the management
practices they left that up to the
growers and one interesting thing about
California growing in California
strawberry growing is that they actually
often used this fumigant called methyl
bromide to sterilize the soil
in between strawberry production years
this is not a chemical that is permitted
in organic practice but conventional
farms including the conventional farms
in the study would free me gate with
methyl bromide in between every year the
organic farms in contrast would actually
plant a cover crop such as one that you
would till in or broccoli or cucumbers
in the same land and then plant
strawberries the next year so that's not
a difference that you actually see
between conventional and organic farms
in New York State because in New York
State methyl bromide is banned so we
thought that this was a very interesting
study but we wanted to see if we take a
similar look at New York State will we
find similar differences so the primary
aim of our study was to help empower
strawberry growers within New York State
by letting them be better informed about
the connections between management
practices that they may choose and the
resulting quality of the strawberries
that they harvest so our null hypotheses
that we wanted to test there were two of
them the first was that there is no
difference in strawberry quality as you
travel from farm to farm in New York
State so in this case we define
strawberry quality as the Brix the sugar
content the titratable acidity and also
the volatile profile or like theorem
aromatic bouquet when you eat it we also
have the null hypothesis to test that
management practices have no effect on
the quality of the strawberry when you
control for the soil type for the
location and the climate associated and
also for variety so the variety that we
chose to work with is called jewel jewel
is a strawberry that was developed by
Cornell University agricultural
Experimental Station in 1985 it quickly
grew to become one of the if not the
most popular variety according to our
supplier it is their top-selling variety
in New York State jewel is popular for
several reasons first off visually it's
a really beautiful strawberry you can
see in the picture they're a little bit
they have a sheen to them they have a
rich red color they're pretty easy to
spot in a field just for that luster
they also ship a little bit better
because they have a little bit of a
higher firmness and they have not just a
good but an excellent flavor so this is
a midseason variety
this means that jewel is ripe from
around start of June to 4th of July and
it's a relatively even production berry
so throughout that season you'll
probably predictably find even amounts
of strawberries in the fields so what
we're going to do today is we're going
to take a look at our farm trials we'll
see what we found and then we'll talk a
little bit about our field trials find
what we found there and then we'll sort
of wrap it all up and talk about the
final conclusions of our study so for
the farm trials what we did was we
wanted to get a glimpse at the variation
of the jewel strawberry as you go across
New York State so for us the relevant
regions of New York State were eastern
New York Central South / southern tier
New York and also western New York so we
wanted to visit at least one farm from
all of these regions for collecting our
samples so I got in my car and I drove
around the state throughout strawberry
season in 2018 and 2019 and I visited
some farms and collected samples in 2018
I visited 22 farms and of those 22 farms
the next year I came back to ten of them
to collect follow-up samples so when I
came to a farm I'd collect two pints of
Reb straw red strawberries from there
you pick fields then I put the
strawberries in a cooler and I transport
them to plant science sometimes the
strawberries would have to spend a night
in a hotel because I was too far away to
yes there's the same day but as soon as
I got to plant Science Building I'd
freeze the strawberries and later we
take those frozen samples saw them and
analyze them for their sugar content the
Brix their titratable acidity and also
we do some volatile analyses so I'll
tell you a bit more about the volatile
analysis basically when you bite into a
strawberry and you chew there are
hundreds of volatiles that are you know
airborne molecules that are released but
the thing is you can't smell all of them
so for our study what we wanted to do is
to find out in a jewel strawberry
molecules are contained that have a
smell that matter to the human nose so
the lab procedure for this is you want
to basically mimic what goes on in your
mouth for those 5 to 15 seconds after
you take a bite in shield so we take
strawberries and we grind them up in a
blender and then we'd actually stop the
enzymes that are released when the cells
are crushed and because you'd want them
to act a little bit but not too much so
we'd add a salt to stop those enzymes
and then we put the puree into a little
vial and there's a little gap between
the strawberry puree and the top of the
vial and that's called the headspace so
the tool that we used to analyze this is
called solid-phase microextraction gas
chromatography mass spectroscopy from
headspace extraction so this instrument
sends a little proboscis into the air
above the strawberry puree and it slurps
up all of the volatiles present and then
it uses gas chromatography mass
spectroscopy to tell you what it found
so I'm actually going to start passing
these around we found a whole lot of
volatiles but we went into the
literature and we actually found the
ones that have a relatively low level of
concentration before they have a smell
that you can actually smell so here's
the list that we found we made a working
list of 6 the first is gamma and deca
lactam when I looked up strawberry
flavor this was the first volatile that
would come up most often if you've ever
had a strawberry milkshake you've
probably tasted gamma and deckle a
ketone it's a really cooked fruit
caramel a sort of take on the strawberry
and it is present in some amounts but in
milkshakes it's often a little bit
overwhelming then there's also little
all little all is really popular in the
perfume industry about 60% of the
perfumes that you try will contain a
little own it's found in a whole lot of
plants it's in basil it's in lavender
it's a lemon
it's a lemony florally sort of aroma we
also find us I so amyl acetate which if
you've ever tasted banana flavored
icky taffy you've tasted isoamyl acetate
it's this really close right fruit
banana II it's kind of pari smell it's
also so low in terms of the
concentration has to be so low before
you can detect it but it's actually used
to test how airtight a barrier is so if
you have a container with isoamyl
acetate on one side and a human on the
other side if the person can smell any
ISIL amyl acetate you know that the
barrier is not airtight it's also an
industrial solvent there's also hexanoic
acid this one might be a little bit
surprising to see in my sweet smelling
list but it is a common plant
metabolites so hexanoic acid is this
love it or hated goat cheese barnyard
sort of smell it's got a really rich and
a fatty aroma but if you take hexanoic
acid and you mix it with alcohol it can
actually form ethyl hex a no.8 which is
a really tropical smelling a pineapple
II slightly waxy green banana compounds
Oh which is an ester and similar to
ethyl Hawks a no 8 there's also FOBT a
no 8 made from the sort of barnyard
smelling butanoic acid which also smells
really tropical and like it says here it
can be added to orange juice alongside
of little ol to make it taste more like
oranges so here's our profile of course
one question that we had after creating
this profile was I was driving around
New York State I was collecting all
these strawberries and sometimes they
had to spend a night in a hotel
sometimes the strawberries went straight
to the freezer
on occasion I picked the strawberries it
was really early in the season other
times it was the very last few days so
how much this is the time between
harvest and freezing and also the
growing degree days experienced by the
plant actually affect the results that
we found when we measured the volatile
profile the sugar in the acid
we find that those factors actually
don't really influence the results so we
see here that in terms of brixon
titratable acidity we have a moderate
amount of variation around a 20% 18% but
if you look at the volatiles you'll see
that the coefficient of variation is
very high even though it's not very
connected to the growing degree days or
the overnight stays so we found this to
be really curious this is all only our
data from 2018 by the way 2019 data we
still have to analyze for the volatile
profile but we did compare the bricks
and the titratable acidity measures for
those same 10 farms that we revisited
and here's what we found so we find that
there is a fair degree of variation in
Brix between within the farms between
years some of the farms don't have that
much variation other ones like farm G
over here just really had a big change
in the measurement I would like to note
that these aren't absolute values every
single one of the differences that we
observed in the follow up here was
actually positive so the strawberries
were more sweet and more acidic we're
not really sure how to explain that but
it is very interesting and it raised
some questions for us about whether the
microclimate might be involved but the
last thing that I want to show you from
the farm data is actually this
correlation matrix that we did so in the
top we have the p-values which shows the
significance of the correlation and at
the bottom we have the r-value which if
it's positive it shows that the
correlation is positive and if it's
negative then the correlation is
negative so we can see that the bricks
in the titratable acidity are positively
correlated with one another we also see
that there's this cluster of
relationships between gamma and deckle
act own isoamyl acetate hexanoic acid
and ethyl hex a noe we can also see that
the strongest correlation is between
ethyl hexanoic and hexanoic acid which
makes sense because one's a derivative
of the other so we see this cluster of
relations we also see that Linna law and
ethyl butanoic are outside of this
cluster
so to conclude what we found in our firm
trials was that neither growing degree
days nor the time between harvest and
freezing within one day will affect the
results that we see in the strawberries
when we sample them we find that there
is variation in sugar and acid between
farms and also within the same farm from
year to year we also see that there is
very considerable variation between
farms in terms of the volatile profile
not in terms of what volatiles are found
but in the plants propensity to actually
create the concentrations we found that
there was a relationship between gamma
and deckle Acton isoamyl acetate ethyl
Hawks a no 8 and hexanoic acid but
little all in ethyl bt a no 8 found to
act independently of Brix titratable
acidity the other volatiles and each
other so with these findings we want to
find out whether things that were up to
the grower actually could have played a
role in the results that we saw how does
the fertility of the soil affect the
strawberries behavior or perhaps the
intensity and sourcing of their
agricultural chemicals to answer some of
these questions we decided to do a farm
trial with within a field that we could
control a field trial is also what it's
known as so for our field experiments we
started preparing our soil for our
fields in 2017 in the autumn we had two
adjacent fields an East Hill Research
Station which we worked with I we
planted them with a cover crop for
applicable plots in the fall of 2017 and
we put the strawberries into the ground
in May 2000 18 so what we wanted to do
with this field trial was we wanted to
replicate the common strawberry growing
conditions that we could observe in New
York State so the organic would receive
nitrogen in the form of compost and
composted chicken manure because urea is
on considered organic organic pots would
also receive straw mulch and an
incorporated cover crop into the soil
of organic pest management practices
we're the only ones used to control for
weeds and insects and diseases the
conventional practice also meant
mimicked common conventional practices
in New York State
so the fertilizer source was urea
conventional plots would also receive a
cover crop and straw mulch and all
conventional plots would receive sprays
of de Bernal which is a pre-emergent
herbicide when appropriate the pest
management used was conventional there
was also this sort of treatment which we
created because we were curious about
the impact of the straw mulch in the
cover crop this was a conventional
low-carbon denoted by the letter S so
the conventional low-carbon treatment is
the same as conventional gets urea gets
stubborn all additional commence
conventional pest management but no
straw and no cover crop so quickly I
just described this this and this but
then you'll see that each of these
columns is broken up into three levels
so each of the treatments had three
levels of intensity as well because even
if you're an organic grower you don't
necessarily grow strawberries the same
way as the other organic grower and
level of nitrogen might be one of the
ways in which you differ or the
intensity of how you manage so the low
nitrogen subcategory would receive 50
pounds of nitrogen per hectare per year
the high nitrogen subcategory would
receive a hundred pounds of nitrogen per
hectare per year so double that and then
the intensive subcategory would receive
a hundred pounds of nitrogen per hectare
per year in addition to extensive
agricultural chemical inputs
more so than the others so for the
organic what that looked like was the
organic strawberries would receive a
mycorrhizal promoting roots tip prior to
being planted and they would also
receive monthly sprays of microbial
supplements sprayed onto their foliage
for the intensive conventional low
carbon and high carbon conventional they
would receive additional sprays of sin
bar which is a fungicide of captain
which is a fungicide and sandbar which
is an herbicide
so again these are our treatments and
they're three levels and after we
planted the strawberries in May 2018 we
pinched off the flowers to promote
runner and Crown development and then
come summer 2019 it was time to harvest
and see how our strawberries did so
right off the fields we collected field
data which was yield and the plant
density then we ran some lab tests to
find out how the leaves are doing in
terms of carbon and nitrogen we tested
the fruits firmness their phenolic
content the volatile analysis and many
of you here actually also participated
in my taste and sniff tests so our
marketable and unmarketable yield is
pretty self-explanatory
it was marketable if the berry was good
enough to give to your grandmother we
would use a window just like this we
marked a 1 meter square window within
the two central rows of every plot and
we only collected yield data from that
Center because we didn't want any border
effects then also within that Center
plot we measured plant density by using
a 1/2 meter long and quarter meter wide
frame which we plop down in
representative sections of the row and
just count the established grounds we
used an Otago strawberry tetrameter
refractometer to measure the Brix in the
take heritable acidity and we used fast
blue BB which is an azo based assay to
evaluate the phenolic content we chose
fast blue BB because it's not reactive
with the score Beck acid which is rather
high in strawberries but is not a poly
phenyl and we evaluated the firmness
using a force 5 pressure meter which I
have a picture of up here so you'll see
that one strawberry will give four
measurements because you poked it four
times the the meter reads the Newton's
of force that it takes to penetrate the
strawberry flesh so here's just a little
look at the various polyphenols and
phenolic that exist in strawberries I
would like to stress that our phenolic
evaluation didn't measure any particular
one of these it just measured the gross
phenolic content within a strawberry
so we also we used the same approach and
results from our farm trials for
volatile analysis for our field trials
what we wanted to know is what are the
relative levels of the volatiles that we
found to be pertinent for this variety
in our field strawberries and do the
differences exist in a way that actually
matters to humans who taste that so the
follow up to this so volatile analysis
was actually what you participated in
the taste test and the sniff test so
with the sniff test and the taste test
our main question was is there a
difference that you can smell so the way
that these worked was that volunteers
would receive a total of 16 strawberries
Oh Marvin and I selected for plot 4 plot
comparisons that we really wanted to
make as a result of this research and we
would pair up the process we want to
compare and we'd give each volunteer a
pair that could be different samples
from those two plots or the same plot
twice and we'd have the people's sniff
the strawberries without looking at them
and just using their noses say do you
think that these strawberries smell
different enough to be different berries
or do they smell really the same and you
don't think there's any difference in
sonication
they'd received the same berry but often
they'd receive different berries the
taste test was exactly the same except
where you actually got to eat the
berries my guinea pigs found that the
tastiest part of the strawberry was
actually the top but that's not
publishable data what we found in the
field trials was that there were
significant differences in terms of
total yield and in terms of foliar
nitrogen content which in turn brought
about a significant difference in terms
of the foliar carbon-to-nitrogen ratio
the percent of the total yield which was
marketable was not affected by
management practice nor was the plant n
city or the total foliar carbon we found
that bricks acidity phenolic content
average berry weight and firmness were
also not connected to the management
practice so we just said that firmness
was not connected to the management
practice but I did want to show you this
graph what
you can see how it's pretty established
and strawberry literature that from this
act on a sort of parabolic curve in
terms of nitrogen so I'll show you
several graphs like this the red bar is
conventional the green bar is
conventional low carbon and the blue bar
is organic and then treatment one is my
low nitrogen plot so 50 pounds of
nitrogen per hectare the two is the high
nitrogen so 100 pounds of nitrogen
perhaps hair and the three is the high
nitrogen plus the intensive agricultural
chemical applications so you'll see that
in the organic because the release of
nitrogen is relatively slow for both
composted chicken manure and for compost
you actually sort of see an increase in
firmness as the amount of nitrogen goes
up but with the conventional and a low
carbon conventional you see the other
side of that parabola because if
nitrogen concentrations get too high
then we also know that fruits can
decrease in their firmness so this isn't
a very surprising result we can also see
in total yields that the best
performance by a fair amount this is in
grams was the conventional intensive
high nitrogen management we'll see in
the folio carbon there is a high degree
of standard error but we'll see that in
the Foley or nitrogen it's very small
and the results are rather predictable
because you see in the organic because
the nitrogen forms are so slow release
it doesn't seem like the foliar nitrogen
was nearly as high as the Plus that
received urea for their nitrogen source
it's also a fun fact that a strawberry
is considered deficient in nitrogen if
the leaf value is below two so you'll
see that the organic plots and the low
carbon low nitrogen plots were actually
considered to be deficient in nitrogen
which is a little bit remarkable because
these strawberries at this point had
received two years worth of their
nitrogen amounts so the lowest and
nitrogen receiving plots had received a
hundred pounds per hectare at this point
and some of them were still deficient
so then in the Fort Lee or
carbon-to-nitrogen ratio it's reflective
of the previous graph in that the
organic treatment has a much higher
amount of carbon relative to nitrogen
than the two conventional treatments do
so the volatile analysis is still
pending this is the results from two of
our nine replicates for all of our plots
we found that in general there is no
relationship between the management
style and the six volatiles that we
decided to track however you'll also
notice that the coefficient of variation
is rather high so it may be true that
when we collect more data and have more
samples relationships between management
styles will actually be unearthed but
with the current sample size that we
have we don't see any significant
correlations the taste test also
reflected the results of the volatile
analysis quite a bit and that people
couldn't taste the difference in both
cases there wasn't a single contrast
where people could do 50% or more
correct identification of the different
pair however the problem wasn't that
people it seems that the problem wasn't
that the strawberries all tasted the
same it seems that the problem was that
they all tasted so different from one
another that even within the same
treatment people would still say they
taste different even if they got the
same berry so for the contrast between
organic intensive management and
conventional intensive management people
were about 30% likely to give a correct
answer when presented with a different
pair or a same pair for the rest of the
treatments it was 10% likely so this
seems that within the field there is
just a great deal of variation that even
when we control for all these factors we
weren't able to control the strawberry's
behaviors to pass these batteries of
tests so to summarize what we found from
our field data we find that even when we
control for the ripeness for the soil
type the participation in the growing
degree days that the strawberries
received the only things that really are
associated with
style are the foliar nitrogen content
and the total yields and by association
the foliar carbon to nitrogen ratio
firmness bricks acidity volatile profile
phenolics
and even the taste and the smell we're
just not associated with management so
the economic implication of this is that
for a strawberry grower in New York
State it doesn't seem that making the
switch from conventional growing
practices will pay off in the short term
this is a tree a three-year field trial
and it's possible about over a longer
time the soil can actually build up
enough of these differences from the
management to see results similar to
what Reginald at all found it very
likely is due to the microbiome of the
plots but ultimately currently it seems
that this is a cost-benefit decision up
to growers we see that there is a great
deal amount of variation as you can see
within a fields both just within the
field strawberry plants next to each
other and within the same field from
year to year we find that higher
nitrogen does give higher yields but
there don't really seem to be many other
payoffs in terms of quality and we also
found that really lab tools and people
can detect all this strong variation and
the management practices that we
evaluated don't seem to be tied to this
variation so some follow-up questions as
we'd be interested in finding out would
be what rule do you night do nutrients
other than nitrogen actually play in
deciding these factors
we're also curious about whether
microclimate might play a role we would
like to know how the microbiome is tied
to the behavior of the strawberry plants
and ultimately we want to know if
organic management does cause any
impacts on flavor how long do you have
to actually do it before the results
sink in and you get similar results to
Reginald at all or something else so
that's all that I have for my
presentation I have some time so I'd
like to really think Gavin sax very much
for letting me do so many of my steamy
analyses in your lab Thank You Marvin
for the Mex
skinfood it's for practicing my
presentation with me so much Greg thank
you so much for letting me do the
phenolic analysis in your lab thank you
so many of you here who have supported
me in ways that are not directly tied to
my research but just with being a grad
student at Cornell and also thank you so
much Ricci and to all the field interns
for really making our research happen in
the fields and thank you all for being
here today that's all I have I'll take
any questions slide it does not pay to
vary from the conventional approach but
isn't that not considering our
preference for an organic strawberry
that's true that's true it's not
considering market preference and this
is only for the short term yes Thank You
Don so what's the difference in price
between organic strawberries conditions
I think at the end of the day especially
if you're a you pick grower it depends
more on the state of your fields and the
time of the season so some of the
cheapest strawberries that I bought when
I collected my farm trials were actually
from organic farms towards the end of
the season I think if you're marketing
wholesale to grocery stores then the
price point can increase a fair bit
though thank you presentation thinking
about what the right way to a consumer
liking study is for something like this
you you for smell
primarily is there a difference but can
you are you aware of what the industry
uses decide if a practice or what was
getting successful isn't like this it
would you care most about is the berries
because there's in fact that is your
most about that if you have to lawns of
strawberry
the average lead exact same but one can
contain 10% disgusting berries at times
extraordinary yeah there was pretty
homogeneous I probably as a producer
what something avoids 10% spent some
berries and so in other words you're
trying to because you're consuming it
individually but you care most about is
not offending consumers than any given
Mary but that's a speculation do you
know what the industry does for berries
or something like this there are they
most concerned about avoiding bad things
in their fruit or are they trying to
achieve some sort of spectacular berries
even if it results in more heterogeneity
so to be honest I think Marvin might be
the better answer for this question but
I can try because it's very interesting
so we had a breeder come in for one of
our classes from Driscoll's
who shared that her breeding projects
that she was involved with now because
Driscoll's strawberries are known as
really being just that bare minimum in
terms of passing for acceptability
they're now trying to breed and very
specifically with an improved flavour
because that's what's consumers want
more than that unfortunately I don't
know I think from holding the defects
positive about the flavour because they
realized that they have a bad reputation
it's not consistent and I have to step
up their game but so when they do that
more important to raise all the various
equally or is it more important to raise
the average in some of the berries so
it's one of the things I notice from
this is there's a pretty big variation
very um I have a part of that these day
even though it looks like a big number
for closure variants for aroma we have a
hard time detecting back to the two
different sizes and variation aroma
we're just not precise with our ability
to smell so as bad probably has
intensive 20% variations so in terms of
like could someone reproducibly detected
but it's still variation keep going and
just doing you big strawberries i have
variation when I try those berries so
you can imagine just wants to everything
but is that is it okay to have half
their berries and a given lot and the
other half don't improve what the asked
because that's that's looking to do it
are you getting a bigger range ignore
the averages the range is bigger that
seems to be a problem at least for
supermarket come strummers thank you so
much thank you any more questions yes hi
Greg so I'm wondering about the impact
that the cultivar had in your study so
you obviously controlled for that use
tool which is a very high quality
strawberry you point down high most
popular one from that one your screen
and they sell so presumably all the
sugars the acids the flavor molecules
are all probably very high in that which
may be masking several differences
sparse if you think they would have
speculation you don't have the data but
just you know if a variety was not as
good as cool you know you had an idea
maybe that's where some of these
practices might come that's a wonderful
question
so the first cultivar that came to mind
when he asked that was actually Honeoye
Honeoye is a strawberry cultivar that is
a little bit notorious because depending
on the soil type that it is grown on it
can taste very good or very bad so that
might be a really interesting one to
actually test management practices on as
well that is very true that when a
cultivar can be more great because it
produces more within itself then that
natural range of production might vary
from variety variety that's really
interesting thank you I think I saw
another hand in the back thank you
it was gross Sencha microbial supplement
so it's a proprietary blend that is a
very secret but it is meant to promote
better blooming and better health and
sort of create a microbial chief I
suppose against any potential pathogens
I think
through displacements likely um so
that's what we used and we also used
Maiko gold which was a mycorrhizal
supplement for the root tip at the start
I guess I believe so oh that's so
interesting it's possible because
actually if you look at some of our
charts in the nitrogen contents is this
because yes it's true the more
intensively managed organic plots
actually do have and that's within the
standard error bar yeah so two times the
standard error is significant so it's
just significantly lower it is possible
Thank You Danny
I any more questions oh please yes
Geneva Hyde have any questions
oh it's mute hi Geneva sorry you're
muted how do i oh I'm sorry could I
please have some help i unmuted it I
think I muted it Geneva hi can you talk
[Music]
is there any research to efficacious it
really varies a lot um but they work it
varies there are some studies that
conclude that they do work and other
it's usually the way that these phrase
are created from my understanding is one
study finds that this microbe which is
pleasant present in the soil has a
beneficial effect upon a certain crop
and then someone with an enterprising
mind says okay it will all purify this
colony and I'll give it to you as a
spray so
normally those sprays are derived from
research but our research on this found
that it doesn't seem that these sprays
are very efficacious after all
in terms of nitrogen content at least
and yield but yeah that's an interesting
question I wish I could answer it more
thoroughly thank you any more questions
oh so we I don't think there's anyone at
Cornell that is currently comparing a
strawberries in greenhouses to
strawberry in the fields I know that
Jonathan Alred is doing quite a bit of
research on green house strawberries but
the way I understand it they're
completely different East's they in fact
even ripen in the wrong direction
because they ripen from the tip up right
whereas strawberries in the field no I
think it's the other way they the
strawberries in the field will ripen
from the tip to the top and the green
house strawberries will ripen from the
top to the tip so they're just they're
strange and they're often different
varieties as well because ours actually
depend on the sun exposure whereas if
you have a greenhouse you'd probably
prefer to use an everbearing variety
that doesn't depend on the day length
for production thank you okay
thank y'all so much this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu